whenever she can how he ovas it's the
flower market in her home city of
Quillin for the pocket money she buys
tree seedlings to plant in the
surrounding area
it's her contribution to the worldwide
Friday's for future protests how he
joined the movement four months ago she
knew China's first climate strike
planting trees is something that's easy
to do and something that's possible to
promote in China
inspired by young people around the
world how he started demonstrating in
front of the local government offices
she was soon as courted away by the
police who warned her of serious trouble
if she continued to keep going but have
taken a lot of courage so I'm hesitant
about that I don't consider myself
especially brave turning her back on
activism was also out of the question
now several times a week she's out
planting trees and hosting about her
activities on social media hopes to
convince more young Chinese to join the
movement University student Danny is
with her today for the second time the
Chinese government has made improving
the environment one of its key goals but
it keeps a tight lid on discussion how
he became concerned about the
environment after reading an article
about plastic waste in the ocean I
started really worrying that such a big
problem wasn't getting enough attention
and nobody would take action I was
terrified every time I thought about it
sometimes every ten minutes I couldn't
concentrate on anything anymore
L'Occitane China's rapid development has
taken a huge toll on the environment the
country is now the world's biggest
emitter of greenhouse gases air quality
is one of people's top concerns but eco
activism is rare in China's repressive
political system the 16 year old student
has now been striking for four months
the parents are worried about her future
but she has no intention to give in to
that pleas to stop skipping classes the
climate crisis is the biggest crisis
ever for the existence of mankind
everybody should do everything they can
to prevent it how he has asked the
relative to let her plant the trees on
his property in China's densely
populated countryside it is not easy to
find uncultivated land the elderly
farmer says he understands and supports
the young activists they used to start
getting cold in September but now it's
summer until October November look at
how warm it still is how he says she has
planted 200 trees in the past six weeks
but even more important to her is to
raise awareness among China's youth
today it's the farmers Sun she explains
what climate change is and he can join
with young people around the world to
stop it joining us now is Sam Gill
executive director of China dialogue Sam
I suspect air pollution is one of them
but give us the top two or three
environmental problems that China is
facing today certainly air pollution is
a major problem not only the choking
smog in eastern seaboard cities but also
in western and northern areas of China
particularly heavily industrialized coal
producing regions but then you've also
got water pollution from agricultural
sources pesticide overuse as well as
industrial sources of water pollution
particularly in rural areas and related
soil pollution his major concerns about
food safety in China if you think of
some of the mass sickening zuv children
from contaminated products or the fig or
the pigs that were plating down the Han
River in Shanghai a few years ago major
concerns about environment and health
and that extends also to protests
against for example the potential siting
of waste incineration plants
petrochemical plants nuclear facilities
called power plants in cities I want to
look at China's international
commitments particularly with the Paris
Accords the international agreement to
reduce emissions how would you grade
China on that and do you think its
position has changed since the United
States withdrew from that agreement
since the United States withdrew China's
stayed the course it may quite a
significant international rhetorical
commitment that it's still in the Paris
agreement that it will stay on track to
meet its commitment to Paris and it's
very likely to come in on its commitment
to Paris to peak its emissions by 2030
the problem is China could be a lot more
ambitious than that there are also
concerns that partly because of the
trade war and the lack of a strong
relationship on climate with the United
States there's been some kind of
slackening of previously quite stringent
regulations on air pollution for example
so you know all countries really need to
up their ambition in the coming years if
we're going to keep global temperature
rise below 2 degrees and that's fair
require quite a lot of attention from
China in its next 14 five-year plan
which runs from 2021 and there's going
to be increasing scrutiny also China's
overseas investments along the Belton
Road and how those affect global
temperature rises I want to go back to
the video report and that young woman
working and putting in her fair share
what is your sense of youth in China do
they care about the environment are they
talking about it on social media and
what are they trying to do because they
can't protest and participate in a
Fridays for future you can't do that in
China there's been some recent polling
about the concerns for young people in
China today and while there's a
widespread public understanding of the
causes of climate change there's not a
lot of scale
about the fact that it's human-caused
it's not really the top priority for a
lot of students and young people one
recent survey shows the education
employment housing healthcare business
opportunities all ranked above
environment not own you know environment
even broader than climate change there
so it doesn't seem like it's the same
kind of priority for young people
compared to how it is in in Europe
United States having said that there are
widespread concerns about more direct
dilution effects of evolution and an
effects of water pollution on on health
and soil contamination and so on and for
better or worse climate is being
addressed in a very top-down way by the
Chinese penguin it's a major political
and economic concern as the as the
government tries to move to a lower
carbon model of economic growth
Sam Gill thank you